>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, D.C.
>> Well, good afternoon, everyone,
and welcome to the
Library of Congress.
A special welcome to friends
of Marlene's who are here.
We're pleased to have you here.
Welcome to the Center
for the Book's Books
and Beyond Author Lecture Program.
The Center for the Book itself was
created in 1977 by Daniel Boorstin
when he was Librarian
of the Congress,
and his idea was the Library of
Congress should be doing more
to reach out to the general public
to promote books and reading,
to which menu we have added literacy
promotion, library promotion,
and basic public outreach on behalf
of books and reading and learning.
And through the years, we
have developed state networks.
Each state has an official
affiliate,
which works with the state itself
to promote, what turns out to be,
in many ways, really
working with author promotion
in that particular state.
And each state plus
the Virgin Islands,
and we hope someday the other
territories that participate
in the Pavilion of the States
of the National Book Festival,
which is another major
area of our interest.
But each state is here, and
a number of those states back
in their own areas sponsor book
festivals and have author events
and get the writers of that --
give the writers of the
state great support.
In Maryland, it started with
the Howard County Library,
but also now is one of 10 state
centers anchored and supported
by the Humanities Council, so it's
the Maryland Humanities Council's.
Initially when we started this,
and I was the founding director
and had the pleasure of going
to all of the states trying
to develop this wonderful idea, I
did approach Pratt Public Library.
It was before the present librarian
was there, and it was a period
of transition, and I
learned a lot about Maryland.
I learned about each state,
that there's only going
to be one official Library
of Congress affiliate
in reading and promotion.
It becomes sort of
competitive in one sense,
and that is you learn quickly that
in some states such as Maryland,
while Enoch Pratt would've
been a natural,
and there's no particular state
government agency called a State
Library, a lot of people felt
it really was one more thing
in Baltimore, and it really
should find a way to reach out,
as each state needed to do.
So it was natural that in the way
that we started in Howard County,
and we ended up in Baltimore,
but it was with the
Statewide Humanities Council.
So that's kind of our story there.
We also have literacy
and reading promotion,
non-profit organizational partners,
and I mentioned the book festival,
but we, here at the
Library of Congress,
sponsor this particular
series, which is aimed
at celebrating new books.
I don't quite have the final edition
yet to show up for the camera.
We are now -- we film all of these
for the Library of Congress website.
But books that have been published
by authors who have made good use
of the Library of Congress'
collections or other collections,
and it's fun for us to be able
to show the result of research,
and the result of libraries,
and to do so through promoting
books and the sales of books.
And today's program, after
our speaker finishes a talk
of around 40 minutes or so,
we'll have a chance for question
and answers, and then a book sales
and book signing at the Library
of Congress discount
of 10% in the foyer.
We are filming this, as I
mentioned, for our website,
for the Library's website,
and for the Books
and Beyond portion of that.
And this series actually started
in 1996, and we now are reaching
around the 350 mark in
terms of presentations.
So through those websites, and also
through the website presentations
for the National Book
Festival, which started,
thanks to Laura Bush asking as First
Lady, asking the Library of Congress
to form the partnership,
has resulted in several hundred
more web author presentations
on the Library of Congress website,
so I urge you to take a look
at that website to get a sense
of what's happening in literature
and writing today, especially,
maybe, in some ways, in biography
and non-fiction, which is kind
of the specialty in some ways
of the Books and Beyond series, only
because another part of the Center
for the Book is the poetry
and literature program,
which has a very active
program in poetry and fiction.
And finally, a new section
-- new center, a mini-center,
which we opened in
2009, was the Library
of Congress' first
Young Readers' Center.
So we have the first place at the
Library of Congress really aimed
at the reading interests of kids
16 and under, who are welcome
to this beautiful suite of
rooms in the Jefferson Building,
as long as they are
accompanied by an adult,
which is an interesting
way of getting
to the subject of family literacy.
So for us, the Books and Beyond
and the Young Readers Program
are extremely important.
Today, as you know, we
have a special presentation
by a Maryland resident,
and this is --
and I'm going to let Marilyn
-- Marlene, excuse me.
I called you Marilyn.
Marlene talk about her book, but it
does have this wonderful subtitle
that lays it all out for us.
So Marlene's book is "Fair Labor
Lawyer, the Remarkable Life
of New Deal Attorney and Supreme
Court Advocate, Bessie Margolin,"
and it's published by Louisiana
State University Press,
which is a press we have actually
worked with before Marlene
on a couple of occasions.
And as we said in our publicity, but
you will learn in greater detail,
during her life, Bessie shaped
modern American labor policy
as a Supreme Court advocate, while
creating a place for female lawyers
in the nation's highest courts.
And you will learn about
some of the obstacles
that she overcame during the
talk, and as I said earlier,
we'll have a chance to
ask questions of Marlene,
and to have a book
signing afterwards.
Marlene Trestman is a
former Special Assistant
to the Maryland Attorney General,
where she started her
30-year legal career in 1982.
She has taught law
at Loyola Maryland --
Loyola University at Maryland,
Sellinger School of Business
and Management, where
she earned her MBA.
A former trustee of Goucher College,
she currently serves on the board
of Goucher's Prison
Education Partnership.
A New Orleans native, Marlene
has had a personal relationship
with Bessie Margolin that grew
from common childhood experiences,
and I have a feeling we are going
to learn something
about that immediately.
Let's join me in welcoming
Marlene Trestman.
[ Applause ]
>> Thank you.
Thank you, John, for
that nice introduction,
and it's really an honor to be
here at the Library of Congress.
I want to thank each of
you for taking time to come
and learn something
about Bessie Margolin.
Through a life that spanned the 20th
century, Bessie Margolin contributed
to three major episodes of
modern American history.
She defended the constitutionality
of the New Deal's Tennessee Valley
Authority, she drafted rules
for the Nazi war crimes trials,
and for more than three decades,
she championed the Fair
Labor Standards Act,
ultimately including
the Equal Pay Act.
Entrusted with the Labor
Department's litigation,
Margolin presented 24
arguments at the Supreme Court,
one of only three women to
do so in the 20th century,
and prevailed in 21 of them.
For 20 years, Solicitors General
assigned those Supreme Court
arguments to her, and she was
the last Labor Department lawyer
to receive that distinction.
She began her legal career in 1930,
when only 2% of America's
lawyers were women.
She served in the Federal
Government under six presidents,
from FDR to Nixon, and
nine labor secretaries,
beginning with Frances Perkins.
She received every award the Labor
Department offered, and by 1963,
was promoted to Associate Solicitor,
the Department's top
non-political legal position.
In short, before there
was an audacious --
before there was a notorious RBG,
there was an audacious
Bessie Margolin.
After retiring in 1972,
however, Margolin seemed
to fade from the public record.
It's not hard to understand
why she deserves to be rescued
from obscurity, but I'd
like to explain how I
came to take on that task.
In the fall of 1974, I was a
freshman at Goucher College,
far from my home in New Orleans.
My high school guidance
counselor had written Margolin,
a distinguished alumnae
from our Class of 1925
of the Isidore Newman School, the
letter of introduction shown here.
Through college, law school,
and into my legal career,
I got to know Bessie Margolin.
She was the first female lawyer
I ever met, and we were connected
by common childhood experiences.
Bessie and I were both wards
of the same Southern Jewish
Children's Welfare Agency,
which educated us at Isidore
Newman School a half-century apart.
Bessie Margolin personified
excellence in the law
and in public service at a time when
women attorneys were discouraged,
if not outright prevented
from pursuing opportunities
available to men.
While protecting the rights of
millions of American workers,
she also advanced the careers
of countless government lawyers
and employees, many of whom sought
out her prestigious
and demanding tutelage.
The late Simon Sobeloff, who was
Chief Judge of both Maryland's Court
of Appeals, and the
Federal Fourth Circuit,
and a former Solicitor General,
offered only two suggestions
for lawyers who sought a
Federal Appellate practice.
They should work in either the
office of the Solicitor General,
naturally, or in the
office of Bessie Margolin.
I'd like to share her journey
from beneficiary of social justice
to its powerful advocate,
and along the way,
I'll offer just a few examples
of the wonderful resources here
at the Library of Congress
that enabled me
to understand her journey,
resources that preserve the needles
of her otherwise undocumented
life amid the archival haystacks
of far more celebrated individuals.
Bessie was born in 1909
in Brooklyn, New York,
the first American born child
of Russian Jewish Immigrants.
From there, to escape New York's
tough and crowded conditions,
Bessie's family made its
way to Memphis, Tennessee.
About a year after giving birth to
a third child, Bessie's mother died,
leaving Bessie's father alone to
care for three very young children.
The Margolin's plight attracted
the attention of a Memphis rabbi,
who petitioned the Jewish
Orphan's Home in New Orleans
to accept the children as
so-called half-orphans.
In 1913, the orphanage admitted
Bessie, age 4, and her siblings.
Proclaimed a magnificent monument
to Hebrew benevolence, The Home,
as it was known, sat prominently
on gracious St. Charles Avenue,
near the stately mansions of New
Orleans' most prosperous citizens.
It was both a stunning
contrast to the humble origins
of its young residents,
and an inspiring symbol
of what each child could and
many of them did achieve.
In The Home, Bessie grew up
with more than 150 other orphans
and half-orphans from
throughout the Deep South.
Its trustees, however,
were not content
to provide mere subsistence
to its charges.
Instead, The Home groomed Bessie as
an all-American girl who shed honor
on the local Jewish community, and
reflected the values and culture
of her prosperous benefactors.
In addition to a religious
education in reformed Judaism,
that preached social justice,
The Home provided Bessie
a robust secular education
at the Isidore Newman
Manual Training School,
where the cutting edge
curriculum emphasized manual skills
and home economics and woodworking,
as well as rigorous academics.
The Home built this unique
school to educate its wards,
first and foremost, but also
admitted New Orleans children
of all religions, whose
parents paid tuition.
Newman quickly became
what it remains today,
one of the South's finest colleges
and -- finest college prep schools.
Bessie excelled in every subject.
She graduated from Newman in
1925 as a 16-year-old leader,
who was comfortable in a
co-ed setting competing,
succeeding, and winning respect.
Besides leading the Debate Club,
and the Girls' Student Council,
Bessie was valedictorian,
and won a coveted scholarship
to Newcomb College,
Tulane University's
Coordinate College for Women.
Bessie spent two years at Newcomb,
ranking among top 10 in her class,
but the audacious Bessie
wanted more.
She decided to attend law
school, something no other girl
from The Home had ever done.
As Tulane Law School's
only woman at the time,
Bessie felt isolated
and self-conscious.
But she and her male classmates
soon adjusted to each other.
When a professor assigned a
torts case involving an accident
in a men's bathroom, no one wanted
to recite the facts of the case
because they were embarrassed to use
the word "toilet" in mixed company.
When one poor fellow in the class
finally blurted out "wash room,"
they all sighed with relief.
In June 1930, at age 21, Bessie
completed her liberal arts
and her law studies with
honors in only five years.
She graduated second in
her law school class,
and was Civil Law Editor
of the Law Review.
Tulane Law School's
Dean, Rufus Harris,
urged Yale Law School's Dean,
Charles Clark, to hire Bessie
or award her a fellowship
for graduate studies.
Clark found Bessie worthy of a
job, but refused to consider her
for a fellowship, because he
did not want to encourage her
to pursue a career teaching law that
simply did not exist for a woman.
Harris assured Clark that
Bessie was, in his words,
a level-headed girl who knew some
things in this world must be taken
as they are, or so he thought.
With her fate determined
by the two Deans,
Bessie accepted a research position
with Yale Law School
Professor Ernest Lorenzen,
an expert in comparative
law and conflicts.
In New Haven, Bessie
impressed both Lorenzen
and a wildly popular young
faculty member by the name
of William O. Douglas, the
future Supreme Court Justice.
With their help, Bessie overcame
Dean Clark's earlier opposition,
and became the first woman ever
awarded Yale's Sterling Fellowship
for Graduate Studies.
With her Yale doctorate,
Bessie moved to Washington
for a new opportunity.
She applied for a job at the
Tennessee Valley Authority,
which Congress had just created
to realize FDR's New Deal vision
of supplying electricity to the
valley's impoverished residents.
Bessie had strong ammunition
to aid her hiring at TVA.
As I uncovered here at the
Library of Congress, as you can see
on the slide, William O. Douglas
lauded her brilliant academic
record, and recommended her to
TVA as "imminently qualified
for a position of responsibility."
But it may have been
Professor Lorenzen,
who wrote what TVA
apparently needed to hear
to hire its first woman
attorney -- first woman attorney.
That Bessie was intent on a legal
career, "as a primary objective
from which she would
not be deflected
by consideration of marriage."
Bessie thus began her federal
government career with a pledge
that she would be married
to her job instead of a man.
Fearing TVA's competition, private
utility companies hurled charges
of socialism that quickly
turned into law suits.
To defend this New Deal cornerstone,
TVA hired James Lawrence Fly,
a Harvard Law graduate and
experienced trial lawyer
from the Justice Department.
Fly made Bessie a key member
of his brilliant legal team.
Two landmark cases that
established, later,
the legality of TVA's
power program, Ashwander
and later the Tennessee Electric
Power Company, overshadowed all
of TVA's work while
Bessie was there.
And Bessie researched,
prepared witnesses,
and materially shaped
the briefs in both cases.
In her other TVA work,
she negotiated contracts
and got courtroom experience
in condemnation cases,
despite fierce resistance to a
woman lawyer from local attorneys,
judges, and even witnesses.
How did she feel about
her chosen profession?
In 1938, Bessie shared her
thoughts in the magazine published
by her Alpha Epsilon Phi sorority.
"Law is still too greatly
restricted for women,
with considerable prejudice
against them," she wrote,
and offered this no-nonsense advice.
"A woman attorney must manage to be
accepted and treated as another man,
and must be willing to take
responsibility, criticism,
and hard work in the same
spirit as do the men attorneys.
She must aim to become one
of the men without, however,
becoming masculine or overly
aggressive in her approach."
Bessie practiced what she
preached throughout her career.
In March 1939, Bessie
joined the Labor Department,
where another New Deal
program awaited enforcement.
The Fair Labor Standards Act of
1938 invoked federal commerce powers
to prohibit child labor,
and to guarantee minimum
wages and overtime.
Bessie was there as every aspect
of the new law was being tested.
Her first week, she
traveled home to New Orleans,
where she won a motion
to quash a subpoena.
By year's end, she returned
home to New Orleans more times
on FLSA matters, including to deal
with the Fifth Circuit's disposition
of a Supreme Court-bound lawsuit
that challenged the minimum wage
for textile workers, then
32 1/2 cents an hour.
The New Orleans Press loved Bessie's
"local girl makes good" story.
One full-length photo,
shown here, captured Bessie
in a pose more cheesecake
than lawyerly.
Why wasn't she married,
the press inquired.
The reporter recounted
Bessie's coy response this way.
"I haven't had time for love."
Then she smiled, "But
I'm not immune.
I'm just uncontaminated."
Dr. Margolin brushed back
a lock of soft black hair.
"So far," she added.
Now Bessie's remark
merits several notes.
First, it was witty, like a line
from a Katharine Hepburn movie,
revealing Bessie's
passion for wordsmithery.
Second, she seemed neither
defensive nor self-conscious
about being single.
And third, it just wasn't true.
I'm going to digress to discuss a
topic I'm invariably asked about,
and that's Bessie's personal life.
That it doesn't fit
neatly within the contours
of her career exemplifies
the obstacles
that an ambitious career
woman faced at her time.
During law school,
Bessie was engaged
to her classmate, the
dashing Bob Butler.
She broke it off in late 1933,
surprising no one,
except perhaps Bob.
Little did Bob realize
that his dream
of marrying Bessie was
doomed from the start.
When he gave her a book inscribed
"to my sweetheart, Bess,"
she inscribed the margins and
blank pages of the same book,
as you can see here,
with extensive passages
from Virginia Woolf's
just-published feminist essay,
"A Room of One's Own," extolling the
importance of women having space,
literally and figuratively.
And then, perhaps you might have
guessed, there was Larry Fly,
Bessie's TVA boss, who was
married with two children.
Their love affair was
a widespread secret.
That's what colleagues, Fly's wife,
and even Bessie told Fly's daughter,
who was writing her father's
never-finished biography.
Remarkably, the romance did
not impair Fly's supervision
of TVA's lawyers, who consistently
praised Fly for running one
of the best law departments
inside or out of government.
Nor did any colleagues ever claim
that Fly favored Margolin at TVA
with assignments or
promotions she didn't merit.
The romance, however, had other
consequences for Margolin and Fly,
who was appointed Chair of the
Federal Communications Commission.
In 1943, Georgia Congressman Eugene
Cox commandeered a congressional
committee to investigate the
FCC, accusing Fly and the agency
of "Gestapo tactics
to control the media
and other un-American activities."
Cox's investigators, including one
improbably named here as "Bugeye,"
as you can see on the
screen, scrutinized Fly's
and Bessie's TVA travel vouchers
to uncover honeymoon trips
that they took together
at government expense,
and they interrogated
Bessie's housekeepers,
landlords, neighbors and coworkers.
But before Congressman Cox
ever questioned Fly publically
about the affair, Congressman
Sam Rayburn
and Lynden Johnson interceded.
Rayburn reportedly told
Cox, "There ain't going
to be no sex in this investigation.
There's too damn many of us
vulnerable on that score."
Although Cox obliged, Bessie's
romance with Fly kept resurfacing.
In 1947, Bessie's membership
in the National Lawyers' Guild
and some other liberal groups
raised a red flag, so to speak,
for the Government's Loyalty Board,
which referred the
matter to the FBI.
Although it uncovered no evidence
of disloyalty, FBI's agents learned
that Bessie had been Fly's mistress,
which they dutifully
recorded in her file.
When Bessie's loyalty was
again challenged in the 1950s,
the charges were again dismissed,
but only after the FBI revisited her
file and her "elicit love affair."
The affair resurfaced one
more time in the 1960s
when now-President Johnson
was considering Bessie
for a federal judgeship.
Responding to a name check
request, the FBI sent a memo
to the White House summarizing all
of its prior investigations
including Bessie's
"elicit love affair"
from two decades earlier.
There are at least three lessons
Bessie should have learned
from her romance with Fly.
Don't get involved with a
direct report, be very discreet,
and don't get involved
with a married man.
Well, Bessie heeded two of these
three lessons when she fell in love
with Bob Ginnane, the
well-respected General Council
to the Interstate Commerce
Commission.
He was not her direct report,
although he was a professional
colleague
who argued a dozen more times at
the Supreme Court than she did,
and she was very discreet.
Friends and family were stunned
when Bessie announced in 1981,
after Bob's wife died,
that they planned to marry.
Stunned not only because Bessie
and Bob were both in their 70s,
and everyone figured
Bessie would never marry,
but mostly because no one knew
anything about the relationship,
which had started two
decades earlier.
Sadly, Bob died in 1984, before he
and Bessie ever realized
their public life together.
The drama of Bessie's personal
life never impeded her work.
In her early years at
the Labor Department,
she paid her dues reviewing
time sheets in damp warehouses,
and traveling back roads
to interview vegetable
packers and log cutters.
She organized the labor
solicitor's regional offices
and trained the regional attorneys.
She began arguing and
winning appeals
in the Federal Circuit
Courts, and started working
with the Solicitor General's office
on cases headed for
the Supreme Court.
Bessie's high quality work
earned her recognition.
Solicitor General Charles
Fahy was delighted
with the Supreme Court
brief she principally wrote,
and her help preparing him for his
successful Supreme Court argument.
When he learned that
Bessie had already argued
in every federal circuit,
he promised she could argue the
next Fair Labor Standards Act case
to go to the Supreme Court.
In March 1945, as only the
25th woman ever to argue
with the Supreme Court, Margolin
argued Phillips v. Walling,
seeking to affirm the
First Circuit's decision
that the Act's Retail Establishment
Exemption did not operate
to remove warehouse employees of
an interstate grocery store chain
from the FLSA's protections.
After what must have
been a lively argument,
Justice Robert Jackson marked the
occasion with a thoughtful note,
the first of several he wrote
to Bessie over the years.
"I hope you were satisfied with
the way The Court argued your
first case.
In any event, you have every
reason to feel satisfied
with the way you took care
of yourself under fire.
I'm sure there would be no
dissent from the opinion
that you should argue here often."
Bessie won the case, establishing
that Fair Labor Standards
Act exemptions must be
narrowly construed.
In 1945 alone, Bessie
argued four more cases
at the Supreme Court,
and prevailed in three.
These, and the rest that followed,
advanced the Act's humanitarian
purposes by extending coverage
and restricting exemptions
to protect wage earners
to the full extent
Congress intended,
and by securing the
Department's enforcement tools,
such as injunctions by
which to obtain back pay.
When Bessie presented her fourth
and fifth Supreme Court arguments,
Justice Jackson was
not on the bench.
He was in Nuremburg, serving
as the US Chief Prosecutor
for Nazi war crimes.
This new and exciting legal pursuit
attracted Bessie, who, in May 1946,
went to Nuremburg to help organize
the American military tribunals
for the subsequent proceedings.
For her six-month tour of duty,
the Army's Commanding Officer
acknowledged Bessie's primary role
in drafting the rules
that govern the remainder
of the war crimes trials of
nearly 200 second-tier Nazis,
including the judges, the
doctors, and the industrialists.
One of the great examples
of the wonderful needles
about Bessie's life that I found
here in the archival haystacks
at the Library of Congress are
pictured here, including photographs
in which, on the left, we can
see Bessie wearing glasses
in the gallery, listening to Justice
Jackson's historic closing argument
to the International Military
Tribunal at Nuremburg,
and on the right, a few days later,
attending Jackson's
celebratory dinner.
In December 1946, Bessie
returned to the Labor Department
to resume her work as
Assistant Solicitor.
She epitomized a new
post-war ideal of glamour,
of a glamorous career girl
succeeding in a man's world of law,
as depicted here when she was
featured in the January 1948 issue
of Glamour, then known as the
magazine for a girl with a job.
But Glamour did not
interfere with grit.
By the time she retired in 1972,
Margolin had directed the
preparation and review
of approximately 600 Supreme
Court briefs and appellate briefs
on the merits, with an additional
150 or so petitions and oppositions
to petitions for Supreme
Court review.
But most impressively,
Margolin principally briefed
and personally argued 177
cases in both the Supreme Court
and the Appellate Courts.
Of the 150 Circuit
Court cases she argued,
she obtained favorable
rulings in 114, 114 out of 150,
only one of which the Supreme Court
later reversed, and it was argued
by someone other than
Bessie Margolin.
Of the 36 cases she lost
in the Circuit Courts,
the Supreme Court later reversed
seven, six of which she argued.
Bessie Margolin was no great
orator, but she engaged the justices
who respected her meticulous
preparation
and her encyclopedic knowledge
of the Fair Labor Standards Act,
and she was able to employ
humor, something not often done
with success at the Supreme Court.
In this 1955 audio clip,
you'll hear Bessie spar
with Justice Felix Frankfurter
in Steiner v. Mitchell,
where Bessie successfully argued
that battery plant workers
whose jobs required them to come
into contact with toxic
chemicals had a right to wages
for the time they spent changing
their clothes and showering,
an issue that has been
revived recently at the Court.
Although you may not be able
to make out what he's saying,
you'll hear Justice Frankfurter's
annoyance with Congress for imposing
on the Courts what he considered to
be undue burdens of interpretation,
an annoyance he frequently
redirected at Bessie.
>> Well, I grant you that that
is not something that may be seen
as a simple decision to make, but
it's no different than many --
many questions of statutory
interpretation as to the application
of the legal [inaudible]
of the statute.
>> I would not [inaudible] statute.
>> What, word for word [inaudible]?
>> No, no, just what you've said.
>> Well, it --
>> That's what you said.
>> When you're trying to get
[inaudible], many times said to me
that the Court should leave
the questions for Congress
to -- and not for the Court.
But, after all, Congress has 400
or 500 people that they have to get
into agreement on language,
and the Court has just nine.
>> That's enough.
>> Which is enough!
>> [inaudible] don't do
[inaudible] Congress.
>> Well, I'm sure Mr.
Justice Frankfurter,
I don't need to tell you that
language is not something
that is easy to make clear.
>> And in this next 1960 clip,
you'll hear how comfortable she was
with the Justices who
were probing her positions
and dissecting her arguments.
Here you'll have her -- hear her,
she was just plain having fun
with the way Justice
Charles Whittaker worded one
of his questions.
>> This offers an opportunity
to straighten out the Court,
and I would like to go on to
show the other clear basic areas.
This is --
>> Just a minute, please.
May I ask just this question?
I -- do you stand or
fall in this case
on your answer to the Chief Justice?
>> What do you mean do I stand?
As I see it --
>> You said --
>> I stand, I stand, I
don't fall on either.
[ Laughter ]
>> Bessie won that case
eight to one with, guess who,
Justice Whittaker providing
the one dissent.
As for Justice Frankfurter,
despite the banter you heard
in the previous clip, Bessie
and he enjoyed a cordial
relationship outside the courtroom.
Frankfurter inscribed a
copy of his book, "Of Law
and Men," to her this way.
"For Bessie Margolin, who
pleases me more often than I,
through no fault of
mine, please her."
She certainly got his attention,
as evidenced by Frankfurter's
notes from the bench.
In one, Frankfurter referred
to Bessie's "deft use
of her feminine charms,"
and in other to her
"exploitation of her
female talents."
I guess you could say
she was accused
of playing the woman's
card quite a few years ago.
In the early 1960s, the
audacious Bessie Margolin decided
to pursue a federal judgeship,
a campaign she waged
for much of the decade.
And not just any judgeship.
She wanted a seat on either
the D.C. Federal Circuit Court,
or the Court of Claims.
With enthusiastic supporters
from Congress, the Supreme Court
and the Labor Department, Bessie's
name was considered by LBJ, himself.
It's not clear what, if any,
role her affair with Fly played
in the decision, but
she faced other hurdles.
One male White House staffer
criticized her fashion-forward
appearance as "flamboyant," and
another opined "that her age, 58,
would tend to preclude
her from consideration."
By 1968, Bessie had been passed over
for seven federal judicial vacancies
on those two courts alone, all
filled by men, four older than she.
The silver lining from Bessie
not getting the judgeship,
at least for us, is that she
remained at the Labor Department.
Promoted in 1963 to
Associate Solicitor,
Bessie developed the strategies and
personally argued the first appeals
under the Equal Pay Act
and, with some ironic humor,
the Age Discrimination
and Employment Act.
By the time she retired in
1972, Bessie oversaw the filing
of 300 Equal Pay Act
lawsuits in 40 states,
ultimately recovering $4 million
for nearly 18,000 employees,
and earning the title
of the nation's number one
fighter for equal pay for women.
Bessie understood that equal pay was
only one part of a bigger blueprint
for equal employment opportunities.
In more than a dozen speeches to
labor lawyers and corporate counsel,
almost always men, she used her
authoritative voice as a veteran
of Fair Labor Standards
Act courtroom battles
to explain the Equal Pay Act,
and the related Sex Discrimination
Provision in Title VII
of the Civil Rights Act of 1964.
One such battle was Shultz
v. Wheaton Glass Company,
perhaps Margolin's most
significant appellate victory
that was never heard by the Supreme
Court, which one commentator likened
to a second Brown v.
Board of Education.
The New Jersey Trial Court had ruled
that so-called male selector packers
in the glass factory were
entitled to 10% higher pay
than the female selector packers,
largely because the men possessed
"greater flexibility to
perform additional duties."
A decision, despite its merits,
that was feared reversal-proof,
because of the judge's extensive
factual recitations informed
by his two visits to the
factory, when even a single visit
from a judge to a place
during a lawsuit is rare.
Yet Margolin convinced the
Third Circuit Court of Appeals
to reverse the trial court's
decision, and to establish
that jobs need only be substantially
equal and not identical
to merit equal pay under the Act.
The company petitioned the
Supreme Court for review,
also known as Cert,
shorthand for certiorari.
At Bessie's gala retirement
dinner in 1972,
former Labor Solicitor
Lawrence Silverman,
today a Senior Federal Circuit
Court Judge for the D.C. Circuit,
described what happened next.
>> As I told you, the Third Circuit,
after argument, was terrorized
into a decision, which was, to
say the least, sweeping in scope.
I distinctly saw a footnote
between the lines saying,
"We'll give you anything you want.
Please don't send her down again."
[ Laughter ]
And Counsel for the other side
petitioned for certiorari.
And Bessie and I discussed it.
Now, you can see the
light in Bessie's eyes.
She had a sweeping decision
in the Third Circuit,
but here was an opportunity
to take an Equal Pay case
to the Supreme Court,
and Bessie suggested
that maybe we should
not oppose Cert,
because it would be appropriate
to have the Supreme
Court see this issue.
Well, I didn't think there was
any way in the world we were going
to get a decision that was better
than that Third Circuit decision.
Now I was by no means sure that
the Supreme Court was going to be
as terrorized as the Third Circuit,
although there are other speakers --
there's another speaker this
evening that can address that point.
[ Laughter ]
But I figured a way to
deal with the problem.
I just sort of leaned back in my
chair and I said, "Bessie, you know,
I've never argued a case
in the Supreme Court."
She said, "We'll oppose Cert."
[ Laughter ]
>> That was just one of the
stories that Judge Silverman shared
with Margolin's more
than 200 guests.
Chief Justice Earl
Warren, then retired,
before whom Bessie had
argued more than half
of her Supreme Court
cases, was guest speaker.
And among his papers here, I
found a folder with correspondence
and his hand-written
notes about the dinner.
Here's an excerpt, an audio excerpt
of Chief Justice Warren's
stirring tribute to Margolin.
>> And in the 33 years of litigation
representing the Tennessee Valley
Authority, the Labor Department,
and implementing the
Fair Labor Standards Act,
she didn't always have
a bed of roses.
I am sure the hundreds of briefs
that she wrote on the scores
of cases that she argued summoned
every one of the 11 Circuits and 27
in the Supreme Court, must
have raised enough hackles
in some quarters to have
made her look forward
to the serenity of retirement.
The 27 cases alone that she argued
in the Supreme Court was
a prodigious undertaking.
The Fair Labor Standards Act was
not always popular in all quarters,
and the flesh and sinews
that were developed
around its bare bones were her
great contribution to millions
of American working people.
Many of these people do not
know who Bessie Margolin is,
or what a great service she rendered
to them, but if they did know,
they would praise her tonight.
In their name, I would like to thank
her tonight, because the bare bones
of that Act would have
been wholly inadequate
without the implementation that
she gave in the courtroom --
she forged in the courtroom
in our land.
[ Applause ]
>> It's hard to top the
Chief Justice's remarks
about Bessie Margolin, so I'll
offer only one concluding comment.
Fair Labor Lawyer, the title
of Margolin's biography,
refers literally to the New Deal
legislation that she shepherded
through the Federal Courts.
But it also refers to the
fairness of Margolin's own career,
the obstacles she faced as
a woman, the opportunities
that influential supporters afforded
her, her use of her feminine charms,
and her non-conformist
personal life.
For me, the title also represents
the challenges I've imposed
on myself to restore Bessie
Margolin's rightful place
in history, and to do justice
in telling her remarkable story.
I hope I've succeeded.
Thank you for your attention,
and I'm happy to answer any
questions you have about Bessie
or my research here at
the Library of Congress.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
We have about 10 minutes
or so for questions.
>> If you could, repeat
your questions.
>> I will do that.
Yes?
>> That was absolutely fascinating.
I do have a personal connection.
>> The audience said this
was absolutely fascinating.
I want to get that on -- thank you.
>> I worked for some utilities
[inaudible] Tennessee Valley
Authority and won.
[inaudible] You didn't say anything
about your own personal
relationship with her.
What was it?
How did you get to know her?
What do you know about her?
[inaudible] friendship with her.
>> Our connection, which
I only briefly alluded to,
really was through the
Southern Jewish Welfare Agency.
Margolin lived, as you
saw, in the orphanage
that stood and operated until 1946.
I was orphaned at age 11, and
although the orphanage was closed,
the agency continued on
and continues to this day
as a social service agency,
and oversaw my foster care.
The wonderful legacy
of the orphanage,
the Isidore Newman School, now --
then and now a prestigious prep
school, honored its founding charter
to admit me as a modern orphan,
who otherwise would've
gone there as [inaudible].
When I came to Goucher,
the letter you saw
from my guidance counselor
really was that she thought
that Bessie Margolin and I
would enjoy meeting each other,
certainly more so on
my part, and we did.
And it was in those meetings,
me as a terribly timid
and know-nothing college freshman
and this worldly, dignified,
wonderful, brilliant woman,
would just in conversation talk
about her career and
people she knew.
And I only wish I had
a tape recorder
for everything that she said.
So over those years, it really --
friendship, mentorship,
just sort of a kinship.
And she was very generous and very
kind to me, less in terms of --
she did, in fact, write
my bar reference letters
when I first applied to the Maryland
and D.C. Bars, and I was thrilled
to find little bits of
myself in her papers
when they came into my possession.
So that was our relationship.
And everything I knew about
her, I sort of held back
to review the evidence I
gathered from her papers,
from the needles I found in
archival haystacks of other people,
but used it to fill in or to
confirm or to second guess,
but I had to make sure this would
not be hagiography, or simply my own
and perhaps innocent or
nave understanding
of a woman whose life was far bigger
than anything I could have known.
The only postscript is I
needed, as part of my work
in the Attorney General's
office in 1993,
to file papers with
the Supreme Court.
We know how rare it is for cases
to actually be taken for review,
but these were oppositions
to petitions for review.
And since I wanted to sign my name,
I needed to be officially
admitted to the Supreme Court.
Bessie Margolin and I had fallen
out of touch probably for eight
or so years by then, but I
reached out to her to learn only
that she was infirm and in
a nursing home at that time.
I was admitted on someone
else's motion.
But just sort of the
link and great history,
that by the day I was admitted
to the Supreme Court Bar
in October 1993, was Ruth Bader
Ginsburg's first day on the bench.
And there was just some
wonderful symmetry,
although it was bittersweet,
because to have Bessie Margolin move
that admission would
have been extraordinary.
Yes?
>> Let me ask you something.
I, obviously, never
[inaudible] the lady before.
>> You are not alone.
>> So it's quite interesting
to hear her story.
I was a lawyer.
I didn't study in America, but I
studied in The Netherlands, right?
A few questions that
[inaudible] forces me to ask.
Obviously she faced
the tremendous backlash
against the New Deal Act
Legislations Act, you know,
that was recognized by corporate
America that basically continues
at this point in time
with tremendous success
at this point in time.
But did she ever comment about
the fact that even the labor law
at its most developed
was very limited.
Blacks were excluded, obviously.
>> Yes.
>> People working in agriculture,
I believe, were excluded.
You know there were tremendous
exclusions to this Act.
Did she ever consider the
need to update this law,
the need to push this
law much further,
the need to radicalize this law?
>> The question I was asked was
whether -- I'm going to repeat this,
and we'll take them one at a time.
>> Okay.
>> The question asked was whether
Bessie Margolin ever instigated
change in the Fair Labor Standards
Act to make it more inclusive
to fill in the exceptions
in the coverage.
To the dealing with any
new law, getting it passed
in the first place is an
extraordinary accomplishment,
and it was well-received, of course,
by those most directly affected.
What I do recall Bessie saying,
and it was in a newspaper report,
she was asked something
about her personal feelings
about the Fair Labor Standards Act.
And mind you, she was
coming from the TVA,
where people who were employees,
who were liberally minded,
were accused of communism
and declared as radicals,
and so her response has
to be taken in the context
of a very young attorney who
wanted to move forward in that.
Her response was, I'm right with
this, the Fair Labor Standards Act,
I'm a New Dealer, you know, and I'm
no radical, but I'm right with it.
I'm a New Dealer.
And throughout her life, the
values of social justice,
which I only touched on
briefly, which were part
of the way she was reared
in this Jewish orphanage,
come through in terms of why
she sought out opportunities.
Obviously she would not have had
a place in a Wall Street law firm,
but she particularly endeared
herself to the mission.
She did not handle legislation,
she might have been consulted,
but it was not her role.
There are many lawyers who
work in the enforcement of laws
who are not particularly involved
in its enhancement or amendment.
And I'll take one more.
>> My next question would be
obviously during her lifetime,
especially at the end
of her lifetime, I mean,
even during my time in law school in
The Netherlands, and University back
in the 1980s, right, when
[inaudible] type of feminist notions
that [inaudible] law, right?
Did she ever -- you talk
about Justice Ginsburg, right?
Her role in that process.
Did she ever later on in her life,
right, obviously she retired,
you said, in 1972, right?
So she's a little bit
before that time,
but certainly the 1960s were pushing
directly into that direction, right?
Did she ever, later on,
comment on, or have anything
to say given her experiences,
obviously, the discriminatory
and the sexist problems that she
had to deal with in her career.
Did she ever, later on, write about,
talk about, discuss the notions
of -- the feminist notions that
were starting to be developed --
>> Yes, well, she was
at the center of it.
She was responsible for the
Labor Department's enforcement
of the brand new Equal Pay Act.
The first time since suffrage,
had a federal law been passed
for the equality of women.
And it was at that time, when asked,
she revealed what she would
claim was her reluctant feminism.
She told a reporter, "I've
never been a feminist,"
which was not true.
She fought all her life
for equal status of women,
but just not in a global way.
She said, "But now that I'm seeing
in my work enforcing the Equal
Pay Act the discrimination
and suffering faced by so
many women, I'm becoming one."
And I also didn't mention
Bessie was a founding member
of the National Organization
for Women,
and was at the founding
meeting in October 1966.
When I listened to the tapes,
the audio tapes that are archived
at the Schlesinger Archives at
Harvard, when she entered the room,
she was met by applause from the
women who were gathered that morning
in the basement of the Washington
Post for this historic assemblage.
So yes, she was very much all her
life a feminist, even though taking
on that term was something that
was very difficult for many women.
And was very proud of it, and
became part of her public personae,
when she went around the country
in addition to litigation trying
to change corporate cultures'
ideas, she was met with ridicule.
She was often asked to speak at Bar
meetings where jokes were being told
about women in the workplace.
And Bessie, rather than taking
offense and not showing up,
would maintain her cool and
she would talk about the fact
that the law and status of
equality had not yet reached a time
where humor could be taken lightly,
certainly not by a representative
of the Labor Department.
But she went on to tell people, and
it was said of her that her coming
to many of these events
was met with --
it was, you know, the force
of God having her come
so that people would listen, knowing
she prevailed in so many cases
under the Fair Labor Standards
Act, did they really want
to take their chances now
with the Equal Pay Act.
Thank you.
Other questions?
Yes.
>> In looking at the credits,
I see Millville Public Library.
I understand all of the
others, why Millville,
and is there an [inaudible]
collection of Bessie Margolin?
>> No, not at all.
There's no extensive collection
on Bessie Margolin anywhere,
except now at Tulane, where I have
personally created a finding aid
for the papers that
her family donated.
Millville, New Jersey is the site
of the Wheaton Glass Company,
and I went there because
they have on microfilm,
newspapers that are not even
available in the Library
of Congress, the Millville Daily.
And I wanted local color about
what it was like for the women
in the Millville plant
who were taking
on what was a family run
dynasty in Millville, New Jersey.
I found very little except, and
this, I guess, is my last anecdote,
a gentleman -- and this is
the wonders of librarians,
who can show you things
you can't ever find.
When I explained what I was
doing there, the librarian came
and relieved me from looking
at reels of microfilm.
And she said, you know,
there's a gentleman here today,
he volunteers as a tutor.
He tells me he worked as a summer
intern at the Wheaton Glass Factory
and would be happy to talk with you.
I went down and talked with him.
He was a college student who
worked there over the summer,
and you never know what
you expect to hear.
He immediately confirmed that
the women did precisely what the
men did.
And, in fact, he always tried
to stand next to the women
on the conveyor belts, because
he found that they protected him,
that is, it was like
an "I Love Lucy" show.
The bottles came out of
the oven, they cooled,
and they had to be inspected
and packed into cartons
to the immediate side of the belt.
And the belt did not stop.
And this young man was so pleased,
because the women always watched
out for him, his words, and pulled
him from having bottles broken.
He also said that the
occasional things that the men did
that the judge claimed
was the flexibility,
was that they would occasionally
bend down and lift boxes
and move them, but he said what
the women did in varying degrees
of work, far equaled --
equaled, if not exceeded,
the value of what was happening.
So, you know.
Always a librarian to the rescue.
Thank you very much.
[ Applause ]
>> Well, thank you, Marlene.
That was a wonderful
talk, and you --
the work you are doing is very
much in Bessie's tradition,
in what you've chosen to do, I
think it's not only worthwhile,
but important, and your
demonstration of the spirit
of Bessie in that it still lives.
So we really appreciate you being
here, and appreciate the little plug
or two for the Library of
Congress, and other libraries,
including small public libraries.
That's a wonderful story at the end.
We're now going to have a book
signing, and you'll have a chance
to speak more with Marlene about
her book, and her own experiences,
and please buy a copy
outside and take advantage
of having the author signing.
One more time, a round
of applause for Marlene.
Thank you very much.
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at LOC.gov